this video is brought to you by skill
share with thousands of classes in
design business and more skill share is
giving away two free months of premium
membership to help you explore your
creativity if you click the link in the
description box below that's for the
first 500 people only by the way more on
them in a bit as a marshal Wild Bill
Hickok took a hands-off approach he
spent most of his day gambling in the
saloon and his deputies knew where to
find him if they needed him and even
though he policed some of the most
lawless towns in the West this technique
worked more often than not even back
then his name and reputation were enough
to make other gunslingers think twice
about causing trouble in the town where
Wild Bill was the law a lot of the
legends and mystique surrounding Hickok
was created by magazines Harper's
monthly in particular but there was a
time when Hickok mice genuinely have
been the most dangerous gunman in the
Old West his list of victims included a
lot of violent men and one bear but
we'll get to that in a minute
the tales about him may have been
exaggerated to an insane degree and yet
the real stories about Wild Bill Hickok
were still full of mayhem murder and
adventure
[Music]
he was born James Butler Hickok on May
the 27th 1837 in a little town called
Homer Illinois which has since been
renamed to Troy Grove he came from a big
family and had four brothers and two
sisters and his parents were William
Alonzo Hickok and Polly Butler if young
James had a sense of justice and bravery
they were likely instilled in him by his
father who was a staunch abolitionists
and even worked with the Underground
Railroad to smuggle slaves out of the
south in later stories Wild Bill claims
that sometimes he would accompany his
father on smuggle runs and had his fair
share of close calls with the law on May
the 5th 1852 William Hickok died
although it's unclear if it was related
to his abolitionist activities or not
James and his three older brothers now
had to take care of the farm and the
family from his early teens Hickok
proves himself quite proficient with
guns as a teenager he would often go
hunting to provide food for the family
James found his first job as a drover on
the Illinois in Michigan canal but soon
enough he headed westward for better
opportunities this will be a recurring
theme in Hickox life as the man never
seemed to settle down in one place for
very long according to some versions of
the story Hickok left because he had to
not because he wanted to after getting
into a fight with another drover named
Charles Hudson Hudson was a bully who
often targeted the younger James for his
practical jokes
one day Hickok had had enough and the
two began wrestling and ended up in the
canal when James emerged his opponent
was still in the water and did not
appear to be breathing hearing that he
had killed him Hickok ran away from the
scene and fled the state although he
later discovered that Hudson had
survived the encounter it's in a matter
anyway as he soon found something more
to his liking Hickok ended up in Kansas
during the brief seven-year period
between 1854 and 1861 when it had been
incorporated as a territory but had not
yet become a state this period is
generally known as Bleeding Kansas
because it was marked by violent
confrontations between pro-slavery and
anti-slavery groups since that was the
hot-button issue for the soon-to-be
state unsurprisingly Hickok was on the
anti-slavery side he joins up with a
militia led by future Union General Jim
Lane which was called the Free State
Army but became better known
jayhawkers allegedly it was during this
time that Jane's saved the life of a boy
no older than 11 or 12 years old by the
name of William Cody he would grow up to
be Buffalo Bill Hickok's reputation as a
gunfighter slowly began to build he
served as a constable for Monticello
Township for a while before accepting a
position with the russell majors and
Waddell freight company best known as
the parent company of the Pony Express
Mail service it was at this time that
the legend of Wild Bill Hickok almost
ended before I got started when the
gunfighter was mauled by a bear some
versions of this story including Hickox
own account said that the stagecoach ran
into a cinnamon bear blocking the road
Hickok got out and shot it was failed to
kill the animal and a fight ensued
another less courageous telling asserts
that Hickox party was sleeping in the
wild and bears simply stumbled on to
their camp and attacked Wild Bill both
stories ended the same way though Hickok
managed to kill the bear with his knife
but not before it did some serious
damage bill had to recuperate for months
since afterwards he was sent to Rock
Creek Station
[Music]
so we arrived at perhaps the most
controversial episode from Wild Bill's
life one that could potentially change
the perception of Hickok from gunfighter
to cold-blooded murderer Rock Creek
Station as its name implies was a
station for the Pony Express and regular
stagecoach is in the southeastern part
of the Nebraska territory it was built
on lands that used to be owned by a man
called David McConnell's who sold his
property to the freight company in
installments if we go by the popular
version of the story McConnell's was
also an outlaw who led his own gang
responsible for robberies cattle
rustling and even murder at one point
the company was struggling financially
and failed to pay an installment on time
on July the 12th
1861 mcconnell's and two henchmen James
Woods and James Gordon went to the
station to get the money he was owed
there he found the station manager
Horace Wellman and his two employees a
man called brink and Hickok who works
there is a stock tender also presents
was McConnell's 12 year old son Monroe
it's impossible to tell with any
certainty what the exact circumstances
were some say McConnell's became
verbally abusive towards the station
employees or that he forced his way
inside to look for money or that he
pulled out a gun
others say that McConnell's and his men
were unarmed and that Wellman came out
with a shotgun or that Hickok opens fire
without provocation
because Wild Bill became a Western icon
the version that made him look like a
hero was the one that was circulated the
most either way the meeting turned into
a confrontation which turned into a
gunfight
soon enough McConnell's had been shot
dead and both his men were fatally
injured nobody on the other side
sustained any serious injuries we don't
know for sure who shot who Hickok
usually gets the credit for killing
McConnell's although some versions say
it was Wellman both men Plus brink were
charged with three murders but were
acquitted on the basis of self-defense
and defense of company property
interestingly Monroe McConnell's always
sustains that his father and his two men
were not armed and were gunned down in
cold blood but he was not allowed to
testify at the trial due to his age and
here's an interesting bit of trivia for
you David McConnell's mites have been
dead but his legacy continued on to
great success his descendants changed
their names to the McCandles and later
included two decorated war heroes as
well as captain Bruce McCandles the
second the astronaut who performs the
untethered spaceflight in history after
the episode Rock Creek Station concluded
Hickok enlisted in the Union Army in the
Civil War he first served as a tea
master and a wagon master bath towards
build up with an old acquaintance of his
general Jim Lane former leader of the
jayhawkers who was now in command of the
Kansas Brigade at this point Hickok also
reunited with an old friend of his
Buffalo Bill Cody who was working as a
scout Hickok wore many hats during the
war giving where he was needed he served
as a scout a spy and a sharpshooter
among other things and distinguished
himself at the Battle of Pea Ridge
Arkansas this might be the time when
Hickok gots his Wild Bill moniker as
arguably the most famous nickname of the
Old West many historians have wondered
why James Butler Hickok became known as
Wild Bill multiple sources agree that
the gunfighter obtains the moniker
during the war for his daring that
reckless ways but the exact origins are
still up for debate also uncertain is
why he would be called bill in the first
place since his name was actually James
according to documents of that era for a
time he went by the name William hay
[ __ ] so that could be an explanation
another possible alternative was that
bill wasn't originally short for William
but rather Bill as in the beak of a bird
before he was known as Wild Bill he was
sometimes called
darker bill because he had a long sharp
nose and a protruding upper lip we know
this for certain because he is referred
to as duck bill in the court documents
for the McConnell's trial Hickok
unsurprisingly absolutely hated this
nickname he grew out his moustache to
cover up his lip and it is feasible that
he started going by William just so we'd
have another reason to be called bill
and look you might not need to train as
some sort of sharpshooter for an
upcoming war but there are other skills
that you could build and that leads me
to today's sponsor Skillshare an online
learning platform
unlike some websites where you have to
pay for individual classes with a
premium membership from Skillshare you
get unlimited access to classes so you
can take as many as you want this is
pretty nice now I'm someone will just
jump into a particular part of a long
class I'll look at that table of
contents and I'll be like ah there it is
part 13 that's what I want to know I'll
just go have a look at that so sites
where you have to pay for an individual
course just to get that one piece that
you want that's not great for someone
who learns like I do and that's why I
like Skillshare I've talked about some
classes I've taken before and I'd still
recommend those there's the email
productivity class from Alexandre Samuel
which really got my inbox that was a
disaster
sorted out or there's another course
about generally building good habits
with Thomas Frank both of those are
great and worth checking out anyway join
more than 7 million creators learning
with skill shapes culture is giving away
two months of premium memberships help
you explore your creativity just click
the link in the description box below
and that's for the first 500 people only
after that it's also super affordable at
only around $10 a month so like I say
two months for free if you're one of the
first 500 click the link in the
description box below and let's get back
to the video
[Music]
the event that turns James Butler Hickok
into Wild Bill Hickok legend of the Wild
West occurred soon after the man arrived
in Springfield Missouri following the
Civil War if you've ever seen a
quick-draw duel between two men in a
western movie it's because of what
happens here because they certainly were
not actually common in the real West
Hickok quickly develops an antagonistic
relationship with another fellow gambler
named Davis tartar former Confederate
soldier according to some acquaintances
the two men may have been friends at
first despite the fact that they served
in opposite sides of the Civil War
whatever dispute came between them we
don't know some say it may have been a
woman but it caused plenty of bad blood
between the two gamblers some sources
mentioned that Hickok refused to play
cards at the same table as tarts so the
latter started loaning money to other
gamblers and giving them tips on how to
beat Wild Bill things weren't going in
Tut's favor on the afternoon of July the
20-years 1865 in fact Hickok at one
around $200 of his money to try and put
him off his game top again taunting the
gambler reminding Hickok that he owed
him $40 from a horse trade according to
witnesses Wild Bill agreed and settled
the debt right then and there but this
wasn't enough etat he then said bill
owed him another $35 from a different
transaction Hickok disputed this claim
mentioning that according to his notes
he only owed $25 which he offered to pay
as you might imagine because Todd
regularly gave out loans to gamblers in
need he was a pretty popular guy in fact
a lot of his friends were there that
night and they all had guns
sensing that he had the upper hand Tut
decided to get cocky he walked up to
Hickok card table and snatched his
wolfen gold pocket watch right in runs
of everybody he then loudly proclaimed
that he will keep it as collateral until
he got the other $10 obviously Wild Bill
was furious but there was little he
could do as he was completely outgunned
but the situation had other serious
consequences for him other than just a
public humiliation at that point his
primary occupation was gambling and he
could not afford to develop a reputation
as someone who was unwilling or unable
to settle his debts because nobody would
want to play against him anymore
so Hickok allowed tar to walk away with
his watch but warned him not to wear it
in public looking back at this this
is worth probably he should have called
her today and quit while he was ahead it
is unclear if he ever said this on the
spot or conveyed the message to build
later through his associates but words
soon began to spread that top was
planning to stroll through the town
square the next day proudly showing off
his shiny new watch Hickok replied that
he would do this if dead men can walk at
this point tup was backed into a corner
we can only speculate on his ideal
outcome of the matter did he actually
want to go to aisle into a gunfight or
did he simply want to humiliate him as
much as possible whatever his intentions
were
he pushed too far everyone in
Springfield knew what he did and what he
bragged that he was going to do so if he
backed off he would have been seen as a
coward the next morning the two men met
and according to their witness testimony
neither one was eager for a fight they
argued for a while and eventually they
went for a drink together for a bit it
looked like the matter might be settled
amicably but their little get-together
ended with Tut storming off angrily what
they said we'll never know but that
afternoon chuck could be seen in front
of the springfield courthouse with
Hickox watch word eventually reached
Wild Bill who knew that the matter had
to end one way or another at around 6
p.m. he walked out into the town square
and headed towards the courthouse and
called out touch everybody else rushed
off to the side since only the two
gunslingers were left standing in the
middle of the street just like in the
movies hikakin SOT exchanged a few words
hesitated for a bit but then pulled out
their guns and fired at almost the exact
same time we cannot say who shot first
some witnesses claimed touch shot as
fast as possible while bill took the
time to steady his aim if this is true
then it paid off their [ __ ] because Tut
missed well here Tim between the ribs
causing Tut to collapse and die the shot
itself was incredibly impressive which
is partially why I caused a sensation
the two men were allegedly standing 75
yards apart at a time when your average
revolver began losing accuracy after 25
yards the gunfight became the stuff of
legend it turned Wild Bill Hickok into
an icon of the Old West but this didn't
happen overnight in fact it wasn't until
early 1867 that an article in Harper's
new monthly magazine about the shootout
propelled Hickok to national fame the
article was written by George Ward
Nichols who honestly deserves about
as much credit for creating the legend
of Wild Bill as Wild Bill himself the
article was incredibly sensationalistic
and was far more concerned with telling
a compelling story than telling the
truth it contains several falsehoods
including not in the least naming the
gunfighter Hitchcock instead of Hickok
but it got the job done
Nichols was also the man who
sensationalized the previous shootout
with David McCanles to the point where
Wild Bill fought off a bloodthirsty gang
of a dozen men single-handedly armed
only with a rifle and a bowie knife one
part of the duel that you ain't often
see in the movies is the aftermath
Hickok had just gunned down a man in
front of the entire town so he's
arrested and charged with murder the
charge was later downgraded to
manslaughter and bill managed to post
bail his trial took place at the start
of August and after hearing from 22
eyewitnesses the jury acquitted him this
verdict was not popular with everyone
and the jury had been accused by
multiple publications of conceding to
the unwritten frontier law of a fair
fight in said of the government laws
which would have clearly found Hickok
guilty
[Music]
now that the business with tarte was
dealt with acog thought about giving in
to law enforcement he first ran for city
marshal in the same city of springfield
but he lost the election in 1867 he took
a brief hiatus from his policing
ambitions and joined the Indian Wars
serving as a scout again here he worked
under General George Custer who a decade
later had gained infamy for his defeat
at the Battle of Little Bighorn also
known as Custer's last stands
Hickok made a deep impression on the
general who went on to describe him as
one of the most perfect types of
physical manhood I never saw his skill
in the use of the rifle and pistol was
unerring his influence among the
frontiersman was unbounded his word was
law General Custer reported that Wild
Bill had two large ivory-handled
revolvers which he always carried with
him and that at the time Hickok was
responsible for at least six killings in
shootouts and many other injuries yet he
had always escaped untouched in 1869
Wild Bill became the city marshal of
Hays Kansas at the same time he was also
serving as sheriff of Ellis County after
having been elected to finish the
remaining term of the previous sheriff
who quit it didn't take long before
Hickok began settling the law in his own
way he killed two men in his first month
as sheriff first was a troublemaker
named Bill maulvi or Melvin who got
drunk and began shooting out random
windows in town and the other was a man
who got into a bar fight named Samuel
straw him both men Joe and Hickok and
both men lost another violent encounter
happened in 1870 when two drunken
cavalry troopers attacked the marshal
prompting him to return far one of the
men who had his knee shatters while the
other died of his injuries the very next
day it seems that the people of Ellis
County weren't very happy with Hickox
tactics and he lost the next election
the gunfighter moved on and became
marshal in Abilene Kansas City with a
much wilder reputation in fact the
previous marshal at notable gunman in
his own right names Tom Bear River Smith
had not only been killed while serving a
warrant but also decapitated this was a
city more suited Hickox trigger-happy
disposition in fact soon after becoming
marshal he was involved in a saloon
shootout where two men were killed
afterwards the local newspaper published
an article defending the marshal making
it clear that
that was the new standard procedure from
then on out it read there is no use in
trying to override Wild Bill the marshal
his arrangements for policing the city
are complete and attempts to kill police
officers or in any way create
disturbance must results in loss of life
on the part of violators of the law
during this time Wild Bill had an
encounter with John Wesley Hardin he may
not have heard of hard and it wasn't as
famous as some other contemporary
outlaws like Jesse James or Billy the
Kid but he had a higher kill counts he
proclaimed that he gunned down over 40
men although other sources credited him
with only 27 kills he wasn't as prolific
when he visited Abilene although he was
still an outlaw we're not sure exactly
how the events unfolded as we don't have
Hickok side of the story and Hardin gave
differing accounts over the years what
we do know happened was that hardened
killed the man sleeping in the hotel
room next to his for snoring too loud
when Wild Bill came to confront him one
of two things probably took place at
least according to Hardin he got the
drop on the marshal disarmed him and
left town or the likely aversion he
jumped out of the window dressed only in
his undershirt hid in a haystack
stole a horse and rode away so we never
got a gunfight between walls bill and
Hardin but we did get one between Hickok
and Phil Coe the owner of the Bulls head
saloon in town for not sure on the
source of the animosity between them but
it escalated to violence and Coe drew on
Hickok during a street brawl Hickok tree
back shot and killed Kerry but then he
made the worst mistake of his life
Wild Bill noticed some sudden movement
and out of pure instincts he shot and
killed the man headed towards him
however that man was Mike Williams one
of his friends and deputies
unsurprisingly Hickok was dismissed as
marshal for his legal blunder and to our
knowledge he never killed a man again
besides his guilt for Williams's death
he was dealing with another big problem
he was losing his vision some say he had
bow coma others opted Alenia but he
would have probably gone blind if it
have lived any longer his gun fighting
days were over
while Bills last few years were
unbefitting of a man once regarded as
one of the greatest legends of the Old
West he was arrested for vagrancy
several times he married an older widow
whom he left after just a few months for
a while he joined Buffalo Bill's Wild
West Show but found that he hated
performing on stage and only lasted a
couple of months before being fired in
1876 Wild Bill joined a man named
Charlie utter and went prospecting for
gold in Deadwood South Dakota on August
the second he was shot in the back of
the head while playing poker by a
drunken gambler named Jack McCall
according to legend he was holding the
black pairs of aces & eights which has
since become known as the dead man's
hands so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe also please do
check our fantastic sponsor Skillshare
who are linked to below and thank you
for watching
[Music]